la reunión buscaba mostrar la unidad de
la pareja franco-alemana que pasa unos
mejores momentos sobre todo después de
que a fines de julio
angela merkel y emanuel macrón
consiguieran lograr aprobar ese
histórico acuerdo en el marco de la
unión europea para hacer frente a la
crisis económica derivada del cob y 219
y es que este verano está siendo muy
movido en términos internacionales y no
solo a causa del virus por lo mismo
merkel y macro no mencionaron su
intención de una europa fuerte e
independiente geopolíticamente se
refirieron a varios temas primero a la
crisis poselectoral en belarús y dijeron
que la unión europea puede mediar en
este conflicto junto a la ose y también
junto a dijo emanuel macrón hablaron
también sobre la crisis en mali y
reiteraron la postura de europa
enunciada ayer de condenar un golpe de
estado contra un presidente
democráticamente electo y dijeron que
para europa el interés más importante en
áfrica sigue siendo la lucha contra el
terrorismo y se refirió también a la
situación del opositor ruso navalny que
se encuentra en estado de coma debido a
un supuesto envenenamiento angela merkel
dijo que su país podría dar la atención
así en la solícita y macro fue más lejos
proponiendo el asilo político para el
opositor de vladimir putin pero lo que
sigue habiendo diferencia de intensidad
entre ambos líderes es en lo que
respecta a las tensiones greco turcas en
el mediterráneo' angela merkel dijo que
su país podía apoyar a sus hijos
europeos e incluso enviar buques de
guerra como lo hizo francia pero para su
país lo más importante ahora es retomar
el diálogo entre atenas y ankara